Hello everyone. Let's get the session started.
Welcome to this session, and this session is entitled
"Claudin-Targeted Therapies from Tight Junction Biology to Next-Generation
Precision Oncologies." I am Kohei Setara.
I'm a German oncologist from Japan, and it is my great pleasure to
be here with two distinguished speakers, Dr.
Samuel Klempner from the United States and Dr. Lin Chen from China.
So today, we're going to discuss several aspects of claudin-targeted therapy.
Why is claudin targetable? What does this teach us
about new category of precision oncology, and what are
major challenges and limitation we must address before
moving forward? So first, I will introduce some biological
background and review how this biology is
translated into clinical validation.
Then following two speakers will introduce emerging and newer
claudin-targeted therapy. And please scan this QR
code and
post any question and comment during the session, or please go to
microphone to ask any question after each talk or during
discussions section.
So let me start my presentation.
So here are my disclosures.
So,
as everyone know, current, our main target is oncogenic
driver,
because tumors are dependent on them.
We can target EGFR mutation, ALK fusion, BRAF
V600E mutation, and now KRAS, as well as the HER2
amplification, because tumors are dependent on them.
And when we hit, tumor shrink
dramatically.
In contrast, non-oncogenic target like claudin 18.2 is
totally different. It is not essential for tumor cell
proliferation, and tumors are not dependent on them.
Instead, it is targetable because of lineage identity
and tumor architecture. This represent a conceptual shift
from targeting oncogenic addiction to targeting the
architectural vulnerability within the tumors.
Claudin 18.2 is a tight junction protein
with lineage-restricted and differentiation-locked characteristics.
It is usually located at the apical site of tight junction complex
in normal gastric epithelium and hidden from circulating
antibody. But during malignant transformation to gastric cancer,
it is exposed to the tumor cell surface with disruption
tight junction and loss of epithelial polarity,
and
it could be targetable and accessible target.
Of note, this expression exposure doesn't always mean
overexpression by gene amplification.
Rather, it is spatial redistribution that create
this accessibility.
So change of tumor
architecture result in tumor vulnerability, which
enables therapeutic targeting by antibody-based
treatment.
Claudin was actually discovered by Professor Tsukita and
Furuse in Japan more than 20 years ago as a
component of tight junction. The name claudin derived
from Latin claudere, meaning to close.
So initial idea is to understand the molecular biology of
tight junction, but this biology eventually achieved
therapeutic targeting
decades later.
To date, more than 20 members of claudin family have been
identified, and each of them has unique barrier
function and tissue distribution.
Claudin 18 has two isoforms, 18.1 in lung and
18.2 in stomach. They differ by only seven
amino acid in first extracellular loop, but this small
difference is enough to achieve selective targeting by
antibody-based therapy without cross-reaction.
And claudin 18.2 is so unique because its expression is
entirely restricted in normal gastric epithelium.
Functionally, claudin 18.2 forms acid-resistant
tight junction strand
and maintain tissue integrity. A knockout mouse model of
claudin 18.2 result in severe tissue damage by
acid and gastritis.
In clinical sample from patient with severe atrophic gastritis or
intestinal metaplasia show the reaction of claudin expression.
So understanding function of claudin 18.2 is somehow helpful
for us to expect possible toxicity, like
gastritis, by targeted agent.
Claudin 18.2 targeted therapy was initially developed by Professor
Tschiemann and Turci in Gan and Der Company in Germany.
They found that claudin 18.2 is retained and membrane
localized in gastric cancer, which is essential as a therapeutic
target. So claudin 18.2 is commonly
expressed in gastric and GI cancer, but it is also
ectopically expressed in pancreas cancer or other types of
tumor like mucinous type of ovarian cancers.
The distribution of claudin 18.2 in gastric cancer has a
U-shaped pattern. Around 30% showed a
loss of claudin expression, and another 30% showed lower
heterogeneous claudin expression.
The remaining 40% showed high and homogeneous expression
of claudin.
Of note, these researches usually applied claudin 18 specific,
claudin 18 diagnostic antibody, which can recognize both
18.1 and 18.2 because binding site is
intracellular common domain between 18.1 and 18.2,
and different from therapeutic antibody like doraptaxumab, which bind
first extracellular loop, which specific to
18.2. But 18.1 expression in gastric
cancer or stomach tissue is quite low or rare, so 18
expression has been considered as equal to 18.2
expression. But recent clinical trial applied more specific
18.2 diagnostic antibody like
SP455.Claudin and ARID fusion is
also detected in less than 5% of gastric cancer, which is enriched in
genomically stable type by TCGA classification.
And this fusion lead to tumor invasiveness or aggressive phenotype
because of loss of a binding site of claudin and
dysregulation of a lower pathway.
So tumor with claudin fusion usually maintain high expression of
claudin fusion, but its function is impaired.
Nevertheless, it could be targetable by antibody-based treatment
because of its high expression. On the other hand, a tumor with claudin
expression do not always show claudin fusion because fusion is a
relatively rare event.
Clinical pathological feature of claudin positive patient were also
reported. We summarize the screening result during a phase three
trial of sorafenib, including more than 4,000 patient,
and identified 38% patient with claudin
positivity defined as moderate to strong expression in
75% of tumor cells. And there's a trend of a higher
positivity in tumor with diffused histology than intestinal or young
age than elderly, but actual difference was relatively small.
So at least we can say that claudin can be detected in any clinical
subtypes in gastric cancer. And these are actual my patient with
very high claudin expression with various molecular phenotype
like claudin fusion, EBB positive, HER2 positive, and a
deficient MML. So claudin can be detected across
molecular subgroup, and it suggests claudin
defined lineage-based phenotype rather than phenotype based
on molecular alteration.
Spatial heterogeneity of claudin expression was also assessed.
There's a relatively high concordance between primary tumor and regional lymph node
metastasis, but there is some reports showing
reduced expression claudin in peritoneal metastasis, possibly
due to some mechanism like EMT. Also, we need additional
research to clarify.
Temporal heterogeneity of claudin expression was also reported.
These four study showed around 40% patient or
tumor with reduced claudin expression even after conventional cytotoxic
chemotherapy. On the other hand, gain of claudin seem to be rare
event.
So this kind of lineage shift might be important for us to consider
appropriate timing to use claudin-targeted therapy or sequence of
treatment.
Immunological profile of claudin positive patient was also compared with that
of claudin negative. We reported high infiltration of macrophage
in claudin positive than negative, but same was not true in similar study from
China applying different cutoff level of claudin, and it showed
more exhausted CD8 T cell infiltration claudin positive tumors.
I believe this kind of discordance might be based on a different
molecular profile of each claudin positive patient as very heterogeneous
tumors. But
immuno profile or immuno context of each patient must be important for us
for selecting appropriate claudin-targeted modality in the very near futures.
And the interaction of claudin and other immuno cells are also
reported. This interesting study suggest interaction between claudin
positive tumor and cancer-associated fibroblast.
Claudin enhance the adhesion between tumor cells and cancer-associated
fibroblast, which result in tumor cell clustering and
infiltration, and claudin-targeted agent disrupt this interaction.
In a very recent interesting study published in "Science
Immunology" also show the interaction between claudin positive tumor
and myeloid cells. Claudin acts like a immuno checkpoint
ligand in myeloid cell to activate immunosuppressive
activity of macrophages, and the disruptome
of this interaction increase anti-tumor immunity.
So claudin-targeted agent show not only cytotoxic activity but
also moderation of tumor microenvironment.
So let's move on to claudin-targeted treatment.
Zorvotaximab is a first-in-class IgG monoclonal antibody against claudin
18.2, which has minimal signal blockade activity since
claudin is not oncogenic driver. But it can induce strong
ADCC and CDC reaction as main mode of action.
Zorvotaximab monotherapy showed modest single agent activity with response
rate of less than 10%, even in biomarker-enriched population.
But around 30% to 40% patient achieved a stable disease as a main
efficacy aspect. And on target GI toxicity are commonly
observed in patient without previous gastrectomy.
In a subsequent randomized phase two FASTO study suggest improved
PFS with fluoropyrimidine chemotherapy.
And then two global phase three studies confirmed the survival benefit of
Zorvu plus fluoropyrimidine chemotherapy, which lead to regulatory
approval of this combination in multiple countries.
On target GI toxicity such as nausea, vomiting, and epigastric
pain are commonly observed, especially during first administration,
and the instance was decreased at subsequent cycle.
And if we do endoscopy, this kind of gastritis or tissue damage are also
commonly observed. And the preclinical study suggest
complement-dependent cytotoxicity or CDC as main mode of
action to induce this GI toxicity.
So these events are relatively transient, and most of the patient could continue
treatment without discontinuation.
However, still this is somehow tricky or challenging to
apply this into clinical practice because it require multiple
antiemetics and long infusion and infusion adjustment.
And also it is somehow expected because claudin is usually
hidden within tight junction. But this toxicity suggest at least a
transient exposure of therapeutic antibody even in
normal tissue.
And actually, more and more recent newer claudin-targeted
agents still show some range of GI toxicity.
So this is one of the challenging aspect of this class of agent, and
we need to improve therapeutic index.And next, the
pancreas cancer showed a different outcome or contrast.
In random phase 2 study of cerpituximab plus fluoropyrimidine chemotherapy,
28% of patients were diagnosed as claudin positivity with the same
criteria with gastric cancer. However, the overall survival as a
primary endpoint was not improved.
Although the detail of the study result have not yet been reported, this
suggests expression alone may not be enough.
In gastric cancer, this is a lineage-restricted expression.
In pancreas cancer, this is a more ectopic expression, so subcellular
localization might be different.
And actually, recent emerging data suggest KRAS
mutations are associated with more cytoplasmic
accumulation of claudin 18.2, which could be
one of the possible explanations of limited activity of
cerpituximab in pancreas cancer, even with
immunochemistry positive staining.
Although we need actual study results to interpret, but not only
expression, but also other aspects like localization,
immuno context, and tumor microenvironment might be important to predict
the activity of claudin-targeted therapy.
On the other hand, cerpituximab modulate tumor microenvironment.
We collect a tumor sample before and after cerpituximab
during phase one study as monotherapy, and it showed increased
infiltration of AFC gamma positive NDK cells and macrophages, as
well as increase of several chemokines, which eventually induce T cell
infiltration. And I think these are helpful
information to consider combination with checkpoint inhibitors.
In also our additional preclinical studies suggest ADCP to
induce phagocytosis as another important mode of action of
cerpituximab, which was not well described previously.
And interestingly, this ADCP activity was not diminished by the
concurrent use of a corticosteroid.
In clinical trials of cerpituximab, use of steroid was not
recommended because of preclinical concern to diminish ADCC
activity. However, exploratory analysis of phase three suggests the
more benefit of cerpituximab in patients receiving
pre-medication with steroid with better tolerability, which is in line
with ADCP as an important mode of action.
In vivo study also confirmed the combination activity with ZOLPI plus
checkpoint inhibitor and chemotherapy, and this seemed to be better than two-drug
combination with ZOLPI plus chemo or a checkpoint inhibitor plus chemotherapy.
And based on this rationale, we have conducted a phase two trial to test
combination with ZOLPI, chemotherapy, and checkpoint inhibitor, and
it showed encouraging activity,
in terms of PFS and response rate, especially in patients with high claudin
expression and PDL1 FPS1 or greater, and currently phase
three Luciana study is going to confirm these findings.
And previously I mentioned the change of claudin expression before and after
cytotoxic chemotherapy. We also summarize the claudin change before and
after chemo plus cerpituximab, and around half of patients
maintain claudin expression, but the other half of patients showed reduced
claudin expression, although some of these patients still maintain low
level of claudin expression. So to eradicate all
claudin-positive tumor cells and to prevent lineage shift,
we may need more active claudin-targeted treatment.
And actually, more than 30 agents have been tested in clinical trials, and
I believe most of these agents will be covered in following presentation.
But here I just want to say, selecting appropriate
claudin-targeted modality shouldn't be based on target
expression alone, but we need to consider other aspects like internalization
kinetics, architectural or immuno context, and tumor
microenvironment.
So future biomarker analysis for precision therapy should
include not only target expression by immunohistochemistry, but also
more architectural analysis by spatial transcriptome, multiplex
immunohistochemistry, or newer types of emerging modality to
stratify patients into right treatment.
And lastly, this kind of experience of claudin 18.2
targeted development could be applied for other lineage-based
therapy or other claudin family. Claudin six is a
reactivated oncofetal protein, which is not expressed
in any of the normal tissue, but it is expressed in various
types of tumors, like testicular cancer, ovarian cancer,
and GI cancer. And multiple claudin six-targeted agents showed
preliminary activity in early clinical studies.
And claudin, other targeted agent for other claudin family
is also investigated, but mostly at preclinical stage.
So in summary, claudin 18.2 is a unique target with
lineage-restricted and differentiation locked characteristic.
It could be targetable because of disruption of tight junction and
loss of epithelial polarity, which result in more exposure of
therapeutic agent in tumors compared with normal tissues.
Of note, this is not overexpression, but architectural
change or architectural vulnerability in tumors, and it
achieved more exposure. And understanding this architectural
vulnerability in tumor, we may open the new category of precision
oncology. With that, I would like to finish my talk.
I thank you very much for your attention.
Is there any question or comment?
Okay, I have a question about the aftertreatment
with the claudin 18.2 antibody.
UhWhich
population that decrease with the claudin 18.2
expression, is it just after a treatment or
recurrence?
Yeah. As mentioned here, there is at least two pattern, who maintain
the high expression claudin or patient who show the reduction
claudin. And we try to figure out which patient show this kind of different
pattern. And actually, who progress rapidly,
show the trend of a more maintain of claudin expression.
And the patient who achieve a durable response with
disease progression after a certain period of time, it show a more decrease
of claudin. But this is based on relatively small
patient experience, and we need to figure out and the biological
reason for this kind of change in the more sample size.
Thank you. Go ahead.
Hi. Great talk. This is Dr. Gutierrez from the Mayo Clinic.
I have a quick question about the infiltration of immune cells after you treated
with the cetuximab in the patients.
So you see an increase, I believe it was NK cells and CD8 positive T cells.
Do you think that's because the tumor is getting
hot? Like what's happening with the tumor microenvironment, do you think there's
any immunosuppression being resolved after treatment with the cetuximab?
Or is it just an artifact just having the antibody and then immune system going in
and attacking the cancer?
Well, it is quite great question, and at this
stage, we don't have a right explanation.
But as shown in my experience with the ZOLPI monotherapy,
there's a trend of increased CD8 cells, and
there is no mechanical reason to increase the infiltration because this is
IgG1 with FC function. So I believe this is
a reactivation after activation of other
immune system like CDC or ADCC or ADCP,
because of the increase of some cytokine or chemokine like CXCL9 or
10, which may eventually induce CD8 T cell infiltration.
But this is just a hypothesis, and we need more data to
understand.
All right. Thank you.
Oh, please go ahead.
Hi. Chris Bobolis, medical oncologist from Sutter Roseville.
So do patients with CDH1 mutations who develop
gastric cancer express claudin 18.2?
There's some literature suggesting low claudin expression
in such patient. But I personally experienced
not a few patients with CDH1 mutation with a high claudin expression.
And actually, I have a two
young lady with a familial CDH1 mutation who have
both high claudin expression and treated by chemo ZOLPI followed
by claudin-targeted therapy. So there is no
perfect relationship between CDH1 mutation claudin, and there
is a patient with low claudin expression as well as a high claudin
expression. So we need to test
claudin in every patient regardless of such mutational status.
Thank you.
Hi.
Thank you. Chang Feng Chi from Peking University Cancer Hospital.
I have a question about the
loss of the expression of claudin 18.2 after
zoledronate. I want to know if you have some data about the
long-term follow-up about these questions, if the
claudin will be return back after
other treatments.
Yeah. This is also a nice question, and I try to repeat
biopsy for every patient if possible, even after second
line or third line, because there is a much ongoing trial
to enroll patient with remaining claudin positivity.
And actually, some of the patient show the reduction claudin
expression after first-line claudin targeted therapy and then receiving
other agent like a PARP inhibitor, and then show the increased claudin expression
and could be candidate for third line claudin targeted therapy.
And also some of patient receiving HER2 targeted
therapy also show the increased claudin expression
after progression. So this kind of phenotype or lineage
seem to be
variable or changeable after targeted therapy.
But we are not sure about the reason for that, and I believe
additional detailed analysis using tumor
sample could give us some insight.
Okay. Thank you.
So there is another online question.
Do you have a clinical data showing claudin expression change after CAR T
cell therapy? This might be question for you or you.
Yeah.
We also find that some of the patients after CAR T therapy, there
will a loss of the claudin 18.2,
but most of patients when recurrence, we
also find the over expression again.
Interesting.
Okay. So let's move on to next talk.
Next speaker will be Dr. Sameh El-Gammal now from the United
States. His talk is about Beyond the monoclonial antibody:
translational rationale for claudin-targeted ADC and bispecific
therapy. Please.
Yes, thank you for having me. Thank you to the AACR and the organizers
for inviting the talk, and thank you Kohei.
Kohei gave a wonderful overview of claudin, and I'm going to try to
fill in a few areas
that there's a little bit more data from the preclinical space.
So here are my disclosures.
This is my claim that I'm hopefully going to be able to try to defend.
But claudin naked antibodies have been a first step and
a benchmark, but antibody drug conjugates and T cell
engagers are perhaps positioned to be the
next generation of therapies for claudin
targetingAnd hopefully I'll tell you a little bit why.
So this is really the promise of T cell engagers.
This is borrowing data from the myeloma space, where the
biology is certainly different and the expression of the target is
perhaps more uniform and clonal. But
you can see on the top is essentially a T
cell engager looking at three-month
progression-free survival, and on the bottom is a standard myeloma
regimen without a T cell engager. So it's an anti-CD38
plus prednisone and chemo. And this is a massive reduction
in the risk of a progression event over time.
And the top line is something we rarely ever see in our tumor type, and
I'll show you a few examples from gastric cancer.
But
I think the potential promise of long-term immune-mediated
control that may be offered by T cell engagers, some of which
these cases are permanent. You see that line is quite flat at
extending well beyond 36 months. That's something that
suggests that these patients may indeed be potentially cured.
Same thing of ADCs, and I conceptualize them as more of a
very spatially restricted way of giving high doses of
chemotherapy that we can generally not administer intravenously due
to systemic toxicity. And this is what's been shown in
breast. This is, again, a very similar dramatic reduction in the
risk of progression. You can see the hazard ratio here is
0.28. This is a trial looking at trastuzumab
deruxtecan, which is an anti-HER2 ADC with a
topoisomerase payload versus another
ADC after prior trastuzumab. So this is a huge benefit in a
patient population that's already been pre-treated.
And this is actually what we see in gastric cancer.
So I think, one, you look at the comparator and the shape of the curves, and you
just see both things going down. So this disease has a worse prognosis.
But the relative benefit,
both the landmark analyses and the hazard ratios, we just don't
achieve the same levels of relative benefit with
ADCs against the same target and the same
drug in the same clinical setting, just a different tumor type.
So what is underlying some of these differential observations and benefit
across different tumor types? There you see the hazard ratio for breast
at 0.2 and similar conceptual
paradigm in gastric cancer with a hazard ratio of 0.74.
And this is a trial that Kohei led.
So why do we need more claudin therapies?
Well,
Kohei showed you very nicely that claudin expression is seen across a
very large portion of upper GI cancers.
And if you use a cutoff of one plus, so
minimal expression in 1% of tumor cells or more,
a paper that we recently published suggests that that's about 90% of
all patients would express claudin if that's the cutoff you used.
Of course, the approved drug uses a cutoff of much higher, and that's about 40% of
patients.
This is largely a tumor-associated antigen, and
expression is limited to the differentiated epithelium of the stomach
and gastric cancers. We do not see
other tissues expressing this, suggesting there may be a relatively wide
therapeutic window that could be exploited for therapies that have high
risk of toxicities, such as T cell engagers and CAR Ts and
ADCs. We do have a benchmark for this
tumor type, so we know where to go to start.
We have seen these drugs be active in other tumor types.
And interestingly enough, and I'll show you a little bit of data, and Kohei showed
you some as well,
intrinsically, gastric cancers harbor a lot of putative
resistance mechanisms to immune checkpoint inhibitors,
which is probably why, although they have transformed our practice, the
absolute improvement is still in the three-month range.
ADCs and TCEs may potentially overcome some of these
barriers.
So what are these drugs? What do they do?
So of course, moving from natural biology far on the
right, you have an anti-tumor TCR that arose
against an antigen expressed on an MHC-1 peptide complex,
binds a specific TCR.
This is what adoptive TILs, this is what checkpoint populations unleash are sort
of the endogenous anti-tumor CD8 subsets
primarily. TCR T cells, of course, you're complexing
against now a known antigen.
This is often HLA restricted, MAJ4,
NY-ESO-1, et cetera, and then CAR Ts, which are, of course,
engineered against a specific antigen.
And TCRs offer a potential big advantage here because they actually
exploit a much larger pool of T cell populations.
Any cytotoxic T cell could, in theory, be activated by a T
cell engager. And there are iterations on T cell engagers, which I will not
go into.
But to
step back, this is essentially the rationale for T cell
engagers. So on,
I guess, the left side for you or the right side,
checkpoint inhibitors are looking to exploit a limited pool of
tumor-specific T cells,
potentially this progenitor-exhausted subset,
and they require multiple signals.
There is, of course, the TCR needs to be recognized against an antigen.
You need a second co-stimulatory signal, and then ultimately that needs to
drive cytokine production, which exerts the effector function.
T cell engagers, in theory, can exploit a much, much larger
pool of T cells because they act in an
MHC-independent manner by creating an immune
synapse, and in theory, there's a much larger pool.
And it may be less dependent on the antigen density.
So this is just a little bit of data from our own work.
This is a collaboration with Korea and a lab at MD Anderson, where we took
sequential samples across a cohort of first-line gastric cancer
patients, so newly diagnosed patients with Stage 4
disease.Single-cell TCR from the tissue
and bulk TCR from the blood, give them one dose of chemotherapy,
add a checkpoint,
and get multiple time points. And really, we just wanted to understand what are the
kinetics of the normal T cell response during our standard
therapies.
But my point is over in the bottom right, that if you
score CD8 subsets for tumor reactivity
using published signatures for putative tumor reactivity,
you can see that the proportion of tumor-reactive cells
predicted is actually quite small, and this is perhaps shown a little bit on
the
right in that the pool that is being targeted by checkpoint inhibitors, and
honestly, maybe even chemotherapy as well, is not
the entire CD8 subset. It's this relatively small, abundant
proportion of a progenitor-exhausted population.
Whereas in the bottom right, in theory, all of these CD8s would be
potentially activated by a T cell engager.
What do we know? We don't know a lot in gastric cancer, which is one of the
things I'm going to hopefully convey, but there is rationale in solid tumors.
I showed you the data in multiple myeloma, but always look at the
pre-clinical data for all of our drugs, and I think one of the messages will
be that we actually need to be better at generating pre-clinical data
for a lot of our newer agents. But this is a
DLL3, which is held up as the success story
in solid tumors for T cell engagers.
It's an anti-DLL3 CD3
TCE, and up top is basically suggesting there is
cytokine release, so that third signal that is key to the effector
function.
In the middle is looking at proportions of CD4 and CD8
subsets in sacrifice mice models,
and at the bottom is what we ultimately want to see, which is essentially
your PD readout, like, did you actually bring more T cells to the
tumor? And where are they distributed?
And what it's shown here, this is
obviously a DLL3 drug, but we don't have data yet for claudin drugs
showing this, but here you can see an increase against the
control in the DLL3 treated. And this actually
translated to clinical success, which is shown on the right.
So now, I'm going to walk you through a little bit of what's known in the claudin
18 space, and hopefully, one of the takeaways will be that we
really need to work together to actually generate more pre-clinical data,
particularly mechanistic data. A lot of the descriptive studies,
even as Kohei was mentioning, when we talk about changes
over time, is it really in the same cell or are these different
subpopulations of cells? So this is ASP2138,
which is a two plus one claudin CD3 bispecific,
and this is some of the rather limited pre-clinical data that's been
published. Well, not published, but presented actually here at this conference a
couple of years ago. These are gastric cancer cell lines expressing various
levels of claudin, and the level you can see over in the bottom right.
In co-culture experiments, you see that we induce cytotoxicity,
we induce killing, and it is across a relatively broad
range, but still importantly, not a very low range.
You see the curve shifted far to the right with the highest expressing cell
line. So the antigen density probably does still matter to a certain degree.
This is another drug from AstraZeneca, looking at tumor-associated
antigen killing, in this case, claudin.
This is a lower CD3 affinity intentionally designed that way.
You can see that in the bottom right, this is a claudin 18
specific binding. There's no binding to the negative.
And in the middle two, basically I'm showing you that the two
questions we want to ask is: Is there a T cell-dependent
cytolytic function in culture? Similarly to what I showed you,
there's clearly increase in production of many of these effector
function-related cytokines. And then they did a quite interesting thing, which
is an area that probably needs to be studied more, is they did essentially a
mixing study of claudin positive and claudin negative cell populations
that were engineered to get at the question, since we know from what Kohei
showed us that
claudin expression is actually not uniform.
So there are going to be claudin negative cells in a large tumor, and can you kill
them? And actually, unless you go down to very, very low levels, the answer
seems to be yes. So there is some probable bystander killing.
This is the clinical data for the Astellas drug.
This was presented at ESMO a few months ago.
And so there is now some clinical foundation to build on for these
agents. So I want to talk a little bit, taking a step back,
what do we know about things that are associated with TCE response and
resistance, and starting a little bit on the tumor intrinsic side and then walking
to the microenvironment side.
So very, very basic. Every target that we've ever looked at in gastric
cancer, this is essentially what you see.
There are patients on the far to one side that have
totally negative. Nowhere in the tumor can you find the antigen of interest.
Most patients, I would argue perhaps all of them, look something more
like the middle, where there is
a lot of intratumoral heterogeneity for every target, and there may actually
be intracellular heterogeneity for many of these targets as well.
And then there are patients who look like the far side, where they are purely
heavily expressing a single tumor-associated antigen.
This is just an example from one of our patients, courtesy of our pathologist from
an ongoing
research project. But what I'm showing you is that is claudin in the middle,
and you can see spatially distributed
claudin, and you look at Pan-CK in the upper right, and you see that there are
areas of tumor that basically have no claudin.
And in the bottom, you see that we have HER2 and mesothelin, and the other is
CDH17.
And there are areas that are claudin positive and CDH17 negative.
There are areas that are double positive.
There are areas that have none, and this is just illustrating what I showed you in
the prior slide.So this is loss, and I question
loss about whether it is truly on the same cell or not,
but that remains to be seen. Kohei showed most of this, and some of this
is from his institution as well. But if you use this cutoff,
10% of tumor cells, about 13% of cases are
fully homogeneous. So they look like that far side where the antigen is everywhere,
but about 87%, so like I said, most have a lot of
heterogeneity in the antigen. And this matters for antigen-directed
therapies like T-cell engagers and ADCs.
So there's ways to improve upon that.
You can look at essentially and/or no gated
T-cell engagers, where you need co-localized target pairs.
So in extrapolating from what I showed you in the multiplex IF case,
you could envision where you need both antigens engaged to
elicit
the response, or you can envision that if the second antigen is
not there, there will be no response.
So this is ways to widen the therapeutic index
with increasing the number of tumor antigens.
It may also help with that heterogeneity where some of the regions will
have no antigen. But we do need to understand from
descriptive studies how often the targets are co-localized or
co-expressed.
I want to talk a little bit about what we've learned from myeloma because we know
almost nothing about
T-cell engager resistance. This is a myeloma study that's a very
nice paper. They have a nice cohort here looking at whole genome
sequencing, and I think I just want to point out that we don't understand
the antigen claudin 18 very well. This is the
structure of GPRC5D,
and in their recurrent samples that were only picked up on whole genome
sequencing, you can see they actually found a pattern of recurrent
codon-specific mutations that directly reduce the binding
of the T-cell engager, suggesting that on-target resistance is
understudied.
This is the structure of claudin. Almost all the drugs bind ECL-1,
as Kohei mentioned.
And none of our assays, when we see patients, when Kohei biopsies patients after
claudin, when Lin Chen biopsies patients after CAR T,
almost never is whole genome sequencing done or even whole
exome, for the most part, of claudin.
It's a very big protein, very big gene, but it's possible we may see some
similar phenomenons where we actually have acquired alterations in
the claudin ECL domain itself that reduce the binding of some of these drugs.
I think that is an area that really hasn't been explored.
I want to pivot over to the tumor microenvironment and talk a little bit about some
areas of interest and resistance.
But certainly, it goes without saying that there's a lot of heterogeneity in
the immune infiltrates in all tumors, and gastric cancer is no
exception. In fact, it may be on the most heterogeneous of
sides. And you have to build a classifier system so that you
can lump patients together and look for patterns.
And there's been many pan-cancer single-cell and bulk
RNA-seq-based classifiers of the immune microenvironment.
But generally, they fall into either two or
four categories, which are highlighted here in this nice review, which I won't
go through. But essentially, for reasons that are not always understood,
prior to any therapy, the tumors exist somewhere on this spectrum.
There is this more immune desert, and at the other end is this immune rich.
And no surprise, immune-based therapies work much better in the immune-rich
subset.
From what we know in T-cell engagers, this seems to hold true, even though
potentially you're exploiting a much larger pool of T-cells and you don't
require a TCR interaction.
We still see that the tumor microenvironment composition matters.
We wanted to understand
what is happening during standard therapies in gastric cancer, and this is just
pretreatment dichotomous classification of patient samples
based on bulk RNA-seq as immune-enriched and
immune-depleted prior to any therapy, giving them one
dose of chemotherapy. Patients split into two groups,
and you can see that patients who are going to go on to have a nice respond, no
surprise, they remodel the tumor microenvironment in a much more favorable way
where you might induce a T-cell engager.
So to get a little more granular on this, we had looked at
within the cell types, what are the gene programs that travel together across
cell types? And we observed something similar to what had been previously
published by Nir Hacohen's group, looking at these sort of multicellular
immunity hubs being inferred from single-cell space, and that's what the
more favorable patients look for.
And so the question is, is claudin actually
a bystander here, or is it driving a more suppressive environment that we
may need to think about remodeling to get to T-cell engager
efficacy? This is a nice study. Kohei highlighted this study, but
essentially they showed that claudin 18.2 specifically
binds this LARB2, which is a
transmembrane receptor that binds MHC-1 in some
angiopoietin complexes, and when it is bound, it drives
suppressive macrophage function and a phenotypic shift towards this
M2 distribution. And so they looked at this.
Does it associate with outcomes? Yes.
Then they actually asked the question of, do this directly induce
suppression? So in theory, the conclusion from this, if it holds, is that there's
actually a spatial interaction between claudin and this receptor
on myeloid cells that is driving them specifically towards a suppressive
phenotype.
So how do we get more patients to look the other way?
In theory, a T-cell engager is going to work better in the
bottom group after a nice response to chemotherapy, for example, where in the
top group where you still have a lot of tumor antigen, but not a lot of immune
cells, we may be selecting and prioritizing patients for ADCs.
So I think we start to need to think about
classificationOf the microenvironment in prioritization
of which therapies you may select when you have multiple options.
Bispecifics may be able to help remodel this, and I'll just give you one example.
This is a higher affinity claudin 18.2 antibody,
so in theory may be active across a broader range of claudin expression,
and it is bound to a 4-1BB, which is, of course, a T cell
agonistic checkpoint. At pretreatment, you can see that these cell types
are already interacting in space prior to any therapy.
And then when you co-culture in PBMCs and
claudin-positive tumor cells with or without this drug, you see an expected
upregulation of some effector cytokines, IL-2, interferon-gamma.
So it would be a great place to think about introducing a T cell engager after
you've remodeled the TME already.
This is the clinical data for that 4-1BB bispecific I just mentioned.
This is continuing to advance and Kohei and Dr.
Shan, I think, are involved in this as well.
In the ADC space, which I'm not going to cover a lot of, because there's been a lot
of talks about ADCs, and I think everybody has seen some version of
this mechanistic graphic on the right.
But this is some preclinical data from one of the ADCs that
is now
almost completed phase three trials, but there is comparable activity
in claudin high for zulbetuximab in terms of binding.
There is higher affinity in claudin low, so it may be active across a broader
range. Of course, you need the payload.
And then they did this study in mixing with claudin positive and claudin negative
organoids, which I think are very important experiments, which are often
overlooked.
So how do we improve upon the therapeutic window for ADCs?
There's a couple interesting ways to go about doing this, but one of them is
looking at target pairs. So this is an old preliminary
data from a grant that we have ongoing with the colleagues at Dana-Farber,
looking at
what surface pairs are mutually exclusive or
overlapping. And one of the conclusions that we observed from TCGA
data was that CDH17 and claudin 18.2, if you added
those two targets together, you actually would cover almost all of the
tumor cells in the gastric cancers
that we were examining. And so this is an idea of expanding the therapeutic
window. Same thing for a T-cell engager as an ADC.
These are targeting co-localized tumor pairs for antigens.
So hopefully, I told you that
this is a very heterogeneous cancer.
There's a lot of variability in that expression of tumor-associated antigens, but
you can actually leverage that. I think the T cell engagers and antibody drug
conjugates offer some interesting approaches to potentially
overcoming some of these intrinsic limitations.
I think we really need to push on pretreatment sampling and really
more granular studies of the tumor antigens themselves to know what
is correlation and what is perhaps more causation.
And really,
some of the weaknesses, in my opinion, as to why these drugs don't all succeed
is there's really an opportunity to do a lot more deeper
preclinical work before bringing them to patients or even from our patient samples.
So hopefully we'll all be working together to do some of that.
This is our team, and thanks to everybody.
Thank you for great presentation, as always.
Is there any question, comment?
Yes, please.
Thank you for your talk. I have a question about is it possible to
test the claudins based on serum-based biomarkers?
Because in genomic, it is difficult to detect on the genomic level, but what about
protein shadings or exosomes or other possible particles
that you can detect from a serum-based level? Thank you.
Yeah. Very good question and a common problem for most of our
IHC-based biomarkers.
It's not amplified, so it's not usually a genetically driven expression
event. There are a couple ways. So there are CTCs that people have started to look
at, and they generally do retain claudin, and you can obviously
detect, but they're, of course, very rare and hard to isolate.
In many of our patients, that's probably not practical.
There's a nice technology that was actually highlighted yesterday, which is
essentially CHIP-seq from the blood.
So looking at promoter methylation of the claudin promoter as a
surrogate for tissue-level expression of the protein.
And actually, they showed some preliminary data for a
few other targets that are problematic for testing from
blood, for example.
We actually have an ongoing collaboration with a company, it's called Precede.
It was started by Matt Friedman at his lab in Dana-Farber.
But they look at
promoter methylation of the gene, and when there's a lot of marks
there, it has been correlated quite well with protein expression in the tissue
sample. So maybe we'll be able to get to
expression-based biomarker testing from the blood, but
it's not commercially available that I'm aware of.
So I have a question. So I agree with you that we need a more
mass approach or a special analysis to stratify patient
to right types of treatment, but how
feasible to apply this kind of complex biomarker
testing in future? Could we use AI to
stratify patient, or could we pick up some of the key biomarker
like a CD3 or something to apply it in
clinical practice?
Yeah. Big question,
and I certainly don't have all the answers.
And it's not my area of expertise, but I think there's a lot of data that's left on
the table, even from an IHC at biopsy, an H&E stain.
So you could, with appropriate segmentation and training, probably
infer regions of the tumor that are claudin expressing, and you
couldObviously look at CD3 as well,
and you may be able to come up with a composite score that says, "This tumor
has X percent of regions claudin positive with increased
CD3, and this may be a patient who's more likely to do well."
So if we can increase the amount of learning we can do from
relatively available data sets, probably, but yes, single-cell
RNAseq from patient biopsies in a clinically meaningful turnaround
time is probably not possible.
There is one online question. What about other
claudin beyond claudin 18 or claudin six?
Could all claudin be a therapeutic candidate, for
example, claudin three, claudin two, or claudin one?
So this is the question. But I mentioned during my talk, there is a
couple
agent for other claudin family, but very early stage,
and no clinical data is presented.
But do you have any comment on this?
No, I think you covered it nicely. In theory, they're conceptually
attractive and could be applied, but I agree, I don't think we have any data yet.
Structure program outside 18 is expression in other
of the healthy tissues. Claudin six is very unique because it is not
expressed in any tissue, but claudin two, claudin three,
it is expressed in at least some degree in normal tissue, although the
expression in cancer may be higher, but we need to
consider safety aspect in such a clinical study.
Yes, please.
Kunumi from South Korea. I have one question about
simultaneous expression in tumor, such as HER2 positive and
claudin positive. We frequently observe towards patients, so
how about combining both HER2 targeting and claudin targeting agent
towards patients?
You take it first.
Actually, we presented some data during T-DXd.
Claudin expression is associated with a poor outcome after
T-DXd, the HER2 targeted agent. So next easy
idea is to combine them together, and particularly if these
ADC apply different payload, like Top1 with
HER2 and MMAE for claudin, is
it something reasonable to combine?
Actually, such study is currently under preparation, but I believe
Dr. Lin Xian, you should have a more experience or idea.
Yeah. We
find that in the HER2 positive, there
above the claudin is a media of the
overexpression. But when
you use the anti-HER2, if the patients with the
claudin and HER2 high expression, the
anti-HER2 is not good.
Okay.
Thank you. So there's also another question about toxicity.
So you will summarize a new kind of modality like a T-cell
engager ADC, but how about toxicity
with this agent, particularly compared with currently available
ZOLBE or other agent?
Yeah. I don't think we have enough clinical data to really make a lot of
comparisons, but
certainly things that we've learned from administration of T-cell
engagers in other tumor types, like the conversion from intravenous to
subcutaneous administration,
of course, seems to reduce the CRS, which is the primary side effect you gain
from T-cell engagers. Whether we'll have comparable or
lesser rates of nausea, I think anecdotally from the
small clinical data set I showed you, the nausea rates are lower,
but it also may be that those are centers that have lots of
experience, including your own, that have gotten better at managing the
nausea in general. So I think it will take much larger data sets to know if
the toxicity is improved by other targeting approaches.
ADCs, you know better than me, but we certainly do see some of the class
effects.
So do you really think for ADC, FC
activation is needed, or could we silence the FC to reduce
on-target toxicity?
Yeah. As you know, there's three claudin
ADCs in Phase 3 trials at least,
and one of them is FC engineered or silenced, and the other two are
not.
Back of the envelope calculations, maybe the rates of nausea look slightly
different, but really not
significant in my opinion. So I actually am skeptical of whether that will
reduce clinical rates of toxicity.
Because still it delivers cytotoxic component into the
normal tissue. But Dr. Xian, do you have any specific
idea to improve therapeutic index or
reduce toxicity by this class of agent?
Because you should have many experience.
Yes. We have not more data, but we find
the bispecific antibody, such as combined with the
TCE, the gastro toxicity
is much lower than the mono-antibody.
But under the ADC is better than
the
mono antibody. So when
you use the antibody combined with the chemo,
the
gastro mucosa injury,
the toxicity is lower. I don't know why.
So I also have a
same kind of experience, but not sure whether which is better or not, but
there is a difference because IgG1 antibody induce
very rapid... occurrence of gastritis or
mucosal damage, but it is not so persistent.
But sometimes T cell engager agent or ADC show
late occurrence or more persistent GI
toxicity or gastritis, and we need more
interruption of treatment of this agent compared with
IGIV agent. So maybe we need a large clinical
data set to compare, and we need more solution, like
some local treatment or more good management.
Yeah.
Recently, we just tried several patients.
We found the patients we used the bispecific antibody, the
claudin 1.2 and the PD-L1.
The
gastric toxicities are much lower.
Oh. What could be the reason for that?
Yeah. I think maybe it's relationship with the
PD-L1 in tumor is a high expression.
Did you change the dose as-
Have not changed the dose.
No change of dose.
Yes.
Interesting. Thank you.
So
we can invite last speaker, Dr.
Lin Shen, for talking about CAR T cell therapy.
So the presentation in her talk is about cellular therapy
targeting claudin lesson from CAR T development and next generation
strategies. Please start.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone. I'm Lin Shen from Peking University Cancer
Hospital of China. It's my
pleasure to presentation. My topic is about cellular
therapy targeted claudin 1.2,
and the discussion with you lesson from CAR T development and the next
generation strategy.
Here is show my disclosure information.
And why the
CAR T therapy selection, the claudin 1.2, because
as the Dr. Shitara have
decided,
this target is high and prevalent overexpression
in the
upper GI cancer, such as gastric cancer and pancreatic cancer.
And is almost tumor specific with a
manageable on-target of tumor toxicity
because this target only expressing the normal,
only the
gastric mucosa. So
the another tissue is a very, very lower expression.
So, also there are some of the
antibody
or ADC, but these patients with the high
expression
of the claudin 1.2 with the more common
peritoneal or liver
metastasis, and these patients is almost
resistant to chemo and
immunotherapy.
So claudin 1.2 is a negative prognostic
marker.
So, for these populations, still high unmet
clinical needs. And when we explore
find
the
gastric T cell
with the high expression of claudin 1.2 surround
the
CD8 positive and PD-1 negative T
cells.
So it is not immunological dessert,
but always baseline is not after
treatment with anti-claudin endpoint 2.
So,
the claudin 1.2 is the ideal target for
CAR T therapy.
So,
we designed a phase one IIT study.
There closed the cohort four. One is the
monotherapy dose expansion cohort.
We confirmed the gastric cancer response rate is reached
55%, and the DCR reached
over 19%. And the cohort two, we
want to increase the CAR T therapy efficacy,
so a combination with a PD-1 therapy.
But it's a surprise that overall
survival and the PFS and the response rate
is dropped
as remarkable. So, I don't know why.
This, the mechanism is not clear.
So, this method is the current
combination with the PD-1 treatment.
In the cohort three, we used the sequential
treatment after first-line with the chemo and
PD-1
treatment. And the OR reached
over 80% and the PFS over 15 months.
So this
method is potential to achieve long-term survival.
And the cohort four,
after treatment with the anti-claudin
1.2,
there are only two patients involved, this cohort, but we
find one achieved PR and another is a tumor
shrink,
with SD. So, we also find the claudin
1.2
is also over expression after treatment with
the Zulbeux.
But before,
under this clinical trial ongoing,
the Zulbeux have not get approved, so the
enrollment is very difficult. But this population
study is ongoing
nowFollow this,
we designed the first randomized control
arm
clinical trial for claudin 1.2 CAR T
cell in GI cancer.
From this trial, we find the response rate
is increased four times
compared with the control arm, and the median of
survival is twofold longer with the
CAR T cell
compared with the control arm.
So the mortality risk
decreased by
63%.
Also, this clinical trial confirmed the claudin
1.2 CAR T cell
efficacy, but we still face major
challenge in CAR
T therapy for
solid tumor because the tumor heterogeneity and
the immunosuppressed tumor microenvironment,
and the special exhausting immuno cell, and
the CAR T cell also exhausted very fast.
So the question one, how do we improve CAR T
persistence and response durability in rapidly
progression GI cancer?
From this PK, we find in the initial phase,
the CAR T PK expression is rapid.
And then the tumor is shrink very fast,
but after several weeks, it's about the four
or
two,
eight weeks,
the
CAR T cell will decline.
So
we must modify the T cell source. We use the early
phases,
want to preserve T cell fitness.
We catch more higher naive T cell
proportion and the lower exhaustion markers.
The aim to increase the efficacy
is avoid the T cell exhausting
status in the tumor
progression
and the later line treatment
time.
And we also use a new lymphodepletion.
Is not like hepatological tumor,
just use the fluorouracil and
cyclophosphamide. We also applies
nab-paclitaxel.
This is a method beyond the making room and reduce
or disrupt the tumor stroma
and increase the traffic of the CAR T cell.
And we also use a repeat infusion, want to
persistent the CAR T cell.
But we found the expansion, the persistence of the CAR T
cell of the repeat
infusion decreased
substantially.
Also, the safety profile is quite well,
but the efficacy is very lower.
And we
want to look for a good immuno
environment, so move to the frontline.
Also we just enrolled five main
patients, but the overall survival and
the PFS is quite better. And
we also, is a sequential treatment after adjuvant
setting in the pancreatic cancer
is also promising
a better
result. Is also the PFS, but also
we observed the
CA 19-9 is decreased remarkable.
So for this population is show a potential,
the long-term survival benefit. And the next question, how
can we precisely identify
responder
and overcome
intrinsic resistance before
therapy? From these two, three patients we can find,
some population have a long-term responder.
The overall survival over two years, just one time
treatment. And one popular only
keep PFS is about six month,
but another one is a rapid
progression after treatment. So how can we
identify long-term responder in advance is very,
very important. So in the first analysis
from the clinical feature,
we find claudin 1.2 expression status is a
relationship with the overall survival.
The high expression is better than the lower and the median
expression. And the patients with no
liver or bone metastasis
is quite better than the liver or bone
metastasis. But it remains challenging
to identify
patients who can achieve long-term benefit from CAR T cell
therapy, even combined with the old clinical
feature. So we explore the TME
profiling. We find the
TZMK positiveAnd
TPX,
this type, the T cell
infiltration, achieve the remarkable
survival benefit. The median overall survival is
18 month versus
5.5 month.
And we also explore on the exome profiling
as the predictor biomarker. The lower
CPP score
with the high response rate and longer
PFS, and this CPP score
consists
three protein level, the
claudin 0.2, PD-1, and the PD-L2.
And we also explore radionuclide probe
for a real time and a non-invasion
detect of the claudin 0.2.
But this trial is only enrolled several patients,
so
now we are the expansion this,
the patients.
And the next question is how do we balance
potent anti-tumor efficacy with the severe
on-target of tumor toxicity? Here show the
severe mucosa injury of the
gastric.
Everyone know in the anti-claudin 0.2, the common
toxicity is gastritis, and with the CAR T-cell is
also like this. And over under
60% patients with nausea and vomiting, and
about 10% with
more than Grade 3 gastric mucosa
injury. But this toxicity is
manageable because we just use one times
or two
refusion. But the one we refusion, the safety is quite
well. It's like a second time to use
the anti-claudin 0.2 antibody. So we
can use a continuous
intravenous infusion of the PPI, mucosal protect
agent, and fasting. As a common about
the three or four weeks, the patients will
recovered from this toxicity. And we
must pay attention another
key toxicity is pulmonary
toxicity, because such
as the mesothelin or Her2 or
EGFR CAR T-cell, there show the
severe pulmonary toxicity, but the
claudin 0.2 is quite lower. It just
show a wide pulmonary toxicity and
it is relationship with the CRS. Just keep
several days, it will recovered. It needn't special
treatment.
But we must distinguish with the disease
progression, such as a right.
You can find the patients with
lung metastasis
in the first several days, the message
T-cell infiltration at the tumor
sites. So now we can find from
the CT scan the tumor enlarge, but
after several days, it disappear
and the all tumor
shrink.
And there are some study use a safety
switch or logical AND gate
by coding use the EGFR
expression
design, use the CAR T cell.
And one patients with toxicity of the gastric cancer,
severe toxicity, we can use
anti-EGFR antibody, can delete EGFR
expression
claudin 0.2 CAR T-cell,
and control the gastric toxicity.
And the logical AND gate targeting claudin 0.2 and
mesothelin can also reduce the gastric
toxicity. So it's very interesting.
And the next question, beyond the claudin 0.2 and the conversion
CAR T, how do we expansion our target and
modality boundaries? The conversion CAR T,
everyone, the treatment cost is very expensive
in more than $1 million. And the patients who were a
while wait, maybe there
are over 20% patients will,
the tumor progression or death, and there are still
7% will fail
when do manufacturing.
So there are lots of off-the-shelf
allogeneic cell therapy like the UCAR and NK
cell or gamma delta T and invivo CAR T
exploring, but it's not like a hepatological
tumor
CAR T-cell does cell therapy.
Here, I show several kind of the
cell therapies on just in the very
early stage trial in solid
tumor.So beyond the CLDN
and the point two, there are some of the
CLDN6 CAR T and
GUCY2C
CAR T for colorectal cancer and the GPC3 for HCC,
or
overexpression of GPC3
gastric cancer, because this population is about
5% in gastric cancer, but the response rate
is about the 20% or 30%. I
think it's very lower, so we must
explore the new model.
So
my conclusion. A CLDN and a point two CAR T cell
is a validation
paradigm for gastric cancer, but we need to
optimize the clinical journey
with the holotics peri-CAR T approach,
such as early apheresis and the new
lymphodepletion and the frontline
application. And we also must pay attention,
precious selection for long-term response
reminder.
We must use the multi-dimension biomarkers,
and we must pay attention the safety profile, the special
target of tumor.
So we must build the clinical management and use
new synthetic engineer models. So
I think next era belongs
the
model innovation.
Thank you.
Thank my colleague, and thank you all patients who
enroll this clinical trial and his family.
Thank you for your attention.
Thank you for a great talk, and I'm always impressed by excellent
work by you and your team for developing this
kind of a new agent and cell therapy.
So
please ask question.
Okay. Thank you. Thank you, Professor Chen.
A very nice work and systemic work.
And I totally agree that I'm also conducting trials about
cellular therapy. I completely agree that earlier apheresis, like
repeated infusion and also frontline
application of cellular therapy would works.
But my key question is, how do you
think, what's the advantage of CAR T cells over the bispecific T
cell engager as they act quite the same, but the T cell engager
has a much lower price, and they do not have to do
apheresis and bridging therapy. Means the patient don't need to wait.
So how do you think, what's the most important advantage of
cellular therapy against the BiTEs? Thank you.
It's a good question. We also do
a T cell engager, and
I think in the recently, the T cell engager for solid
tumor is not good.
That target must combination with another
target, such as a CLDN and EGFR
and another target. But the
monotherapies are still very lower.
It's not like the-
CAR T cell
... CAR T cell. Now, CAR T cell therapy, the tumor
shrink very fast,
and the response rate is higher if the target is
suitable.
But the
toxicity is a difference, and the response rate is
also the difference. So I think
maybe in the future, we can combination with two method.
Okay. Thank you. And I want to follow another question.
mechanically, why is
cellular therapy has a better performance against
the BiTEs? In your opinion, what's the potential
mechanism behind these two totally different clinical
performance?
I think the clinical performance with the
patients, the relationship with the status
of the immuno environment and the T cell
source is a
difference. If we selection the
very light,
the T cell with the
exhausting.
So
we show the selection, the immuno environment is
quite better.
Okay. Thank you. Thank you very much.
So I agree with you that T cell engager still show there's some
kind of limited single-agent activity because of the
immunosuppressive tumor microenvironment or relatively
some mentioned proof, but there's still limited activated T
cells could be the reason for that.
So my question for your CAR T is the combination with
anti-PD-1. It is interesting to see lower activity-
Yeah
... or response rate. What could be the reason for that?
Or did you check persistency of this CAR T when we
combine with anti-PD-1 or as a monotherapy?
Have not yet check it.
Okay.
But it's very surprise,
because from the mechanism, it should have a
synergy take of
combined with the PD-1. But it's only
there are several patients, so we are
in the near future, we must expansion the patients-
Yeah
... and check the PD-L1 expression and the immuno
environment status.
Yeah. So if I need to explain this, maybe anti-PD-1
activate effect, this is a key concept, but still it activate
other immunosuppressive cell, like Treg cells, and it may-...
negatively affect the CAR T cell activity.
So I agree with you to check tumor microenvironment or
persistency of CAR T might be interesting. Thank you.
Thank you.
Go ahead.
Professor Shen, thank you for sharing your wonderful talk.
I have a question, is that in hematological malignancies, the
disease condition or disease burden before CAR T
infusion is critical. So in that, in the solid tumor such as gastric
cancer, do you suggest debulking or cytoreductive systemic
therapy? And how is the extent of this systemic therapy
should be given prior to this CAR T infusion? Thank you.
Yes. The
clinical trial is ongoing,
is the front line after treatment with the
chemo combination with the PD-1. Because the
tumor burden is decreased, the environment
change a lot. So after then,
special for patients with the SD or PR,
use the CAR T cell, the response rate is higher and
can prolonger the PFS.
But the
treatment cost is too expensive, so no pharmaceutical
company want to do like first line.
So we just can use the small, simple
Phase 2 or Phase 1 study, but this trial is ongoing.
This is a follow-up question. How we can best sequence this kind
of a modality like a chemo plus
mono or T-cell engager, ADC agent with
checkpoint inhibitor combination or CAR T cell therapy?
This could be question for both of you.
In the first, I
have a idea. Maybe we can use the
bridge
treatment
before CAR T cell, use the claudin and a
point-two
antibody and a
T-cell engager.
Maybe it can change the environment.
But I worry about the loss of the claudin point-two,
so which is a best choice, we have no more
idea. But for
now, there are more
and more competition, the
mono antibody,
bispecific antibody, ADC, and the CAR T cell.
And in the future, I'm trusting about how
to management this sequential.
Maybe the bispecific antibody in the front line,
and then the CAR T cell, and then the
ADC,
maybe. I don't know.
Yeah. I think that
it's a complicated problem, but if
you could study every patient to the level of depth that we can do
post hoc, you could probably tease this apart.
For example,
before we start any therapy, there are some patients who their tumor is
extremely fibrotic, it has no T cells, it has
very sparse tumor cells, and that person is probably destined
not to do well with
probably a T cell engager or even a checkpoint inhibitor.
And then the other spectrum, there are patients whose baseline microenvironment is
already enriched for T cells that have already recognized there's a preexisting
immune response, and that's a much more fertile environment
to push on the T cell side as opposed to pushing on another
TME component, whether it's the myeloid or the fibroblast component.
So I think a little better patient stratification will
probably select for the people who would do best with a
given strategy, but I'm not sure you can apply or we will be able to
apply
some broad strategy that we can say that in general, ADC is the
best, but maybe the best for this person.
But as a strategy, I think it will be hard.
So more segmentation by tumor biomarker profile
context must be important in future.
Yeah, I completely agree with you.
So any additional questions?
So if not, maybe we can close this session.
Thank you for wonderful speech by both of you, and thank you for attending.